let's say that i have some
set
v
that is a subspace
subspace
in
r
n and just as a reminder what does it
mean that's just some set or some subset
of rn where if i take any two members of
that subset so let's say take the
members a and b they're both members of
my subspace
by the fact that this is a subspace we
then know
that the addition of these two vectors
or a plus b is also in my subspace and
this this is our closure
closure under
under addition
addition
and by the fact that it's a subspace we
also know that if we multiply any member
of our subspace by a scalar so the fact
that those guys are members of our
subspace we also know that if i pick one
of them let's say a and i multiply a by
some scalar that this is also going to
be a member of our subspace and we
sometimes call this closure
under
scalar multiplication scalar
multiplication
and then a somewhat redundant statement
is that v will it must contain the zero
vector and that's just that's true of
all subspaces v
let me write it this way the zero vector
is a member of v and it would be the
zero vector with n components here
because v is a subspace of r n and why i
say that's redundant because you could
if i say that any multiple of these
vectors is also in v i could just set
the scalar to be equal to zero so this
statement kind of takes this statement
into account but in a lot of textbooks
they'll always write oh and the zero
vector has to be a member of v
although that's kind of redundant with
the closure under scalar multiplication
fair enough
now let's say that i also have
some transformation t
i have some transformation t
it is a mapping
a function from rn
to
r
m
what i want to understand in this video
is i have a subspace right here v
i want to understand whether the
transformation of the subspace
so the transformation of the subspace
what did we call that we call that
the image
of our subspace or our subset either way
the image of v under
under
t and the last video just to kind of
help you visualize it how how did that
work or you know we had some subset of
rn that looked like this was a triangle
that looks something like that
right and that was in rn this was
actually an r2 it was a triangle that
looks something like that and we figured
out its image
under t so we went from r2 to to r2
and we had our transformation and it
ended up looking something like this if
i remember it properly
ended up looking like a actually i don't
remember it fully but it was like a
triangle that was skewed like this
rotated so it was a it was actually i
think it was more like
i think that's right it was rotated a
bit to the clockwise like that it was
skewed but you know what the exact
particulars of that last video aren't
what matter that what matters is that
you are able to visualize what an image
under transformation means it means you
take some subset of r2 the all of the
vectors that define this triangle right
here that's some subset of r2 you
transform all of them and then you get
some subset in your codomain and this is
this is the you could call this the
image because the transformation of that
triangle
or the you know if we call this s it's
equal to the transformation of s or you
could say it's the image
always com the image
of you could call it the set s but maybe
it helps you to visualize because it's
the image of
this triangle under
under t or maybe even a neater way of
thinking about it is this triangle
that skewed rotated triangle
this one is the image of this
kind of right triangle
under t i think that might make a little
bit of visual sense to you and just as a
bit of reminder in that last video these
triangles these weren't subspaces
and you know just as you could take
scalar multiples of some of the vectors
that are subsets of that are members of
this of this triangle and you'll find
that they're not going to be in that
triangle so these this wasn't a subspace
this was just a subset of r2 all subsets
are not subspaces but all subspaces are
definitely subsets although something
can be a subset of itself i don't want
to wander off too much but this just
helps you visualize what we mean by an
image it means all of the
all of the
all of the the vectors that are mapped
to
from the members of your subset
so i want to know whether the whether
the the image of v under t is a subspace
is
a
sub space
so in order for to be a subspace if i
take the transformation if i let's let
me find two members of t well clearly if
i take the transformation of any members
of v i'm getting members of the image
right so i can write this
you know clearly the transformation of a
and the transformations of b
these are both members of our images of
v under t
these are both
members of that right there so my
question to you is
my question to you is what is the
transformation
transformation of a plus the
transformation of b and the way i've
written this these are two arbitrary
members of our image of v under t or
maybe i should call it t of capital v
these are two arbitrary members so what
is this equal to well we know from our
properties our definition of linear
transformations this is equal to the
transformation the sum of the
transformations of two vectors is equal
to the transformation of the sum of
their vectors
now is this
is the transformation of a plus b
is this a member
of tv
is it a member of our image
well a plus b is a member of v and the
image contains the transformation of all
of the members of v
so the image contains the transformation
of this guy this guy a plus b is a
member of v
so you're taking the transformation of a
member of v which by definition is in
your image of v under t so this is
definitely true
now let's ask the next question
if i take
if i take a scalar multiple
of some member of my image of v under t
or my t of capital v right there if i
take the
sum scalar what is this equal to by our
by definition for linear transformation
this is the same thing as a
transformation of the scalar
times the vector
now is this going to be a member of
our image of v under t
well we know that c a is definitely in v
right that's from the definition of a
subspace this is definitely in v and so
if this is in v the transformation of
this has to be in v's image under d so
this is in this is also a member of v
and obviously you can set this equal to
zero you could set this equal to zero
the zero vector is a member of v so any
transformation of if you just put a zero
here you'll get the zero vector so the
zero vector is definitely i don't care
what this is if you multiply it times
zero you're going to get the zero vector
so the zero vector is definitely also a
member of t v so we come on the result
that
t
the image of v under t is
a subspace
is a subspace which is a useful result
which we'll be able to use later on but
this i guess might naturally to the
question what if what if we what if we
go you know everything we've been
dealing that so far have been sub space
subsets in the case of this triangle or
subspaces in the case of v but what if i
were to take the image what if you know
i could i could take what if i take the
image of
rn
under t right this is the image
of
rn
under
t let's think about what this means
this means what do we get when we take
any member of our n
what is the set of all of the vectors
that when we take the transformation of
all of the members of rn let me write
this this is equal to
the set of the transformation of
all of the x's where each x
is a member of rn so you take each of
the members of rn and transform them and
you create this new set this is the
image of rn under
t
the image of rn under t
well there's a couple of ways you can
think of this this is remember when we
defined let's see t goes from
t is a mapping from r n
to
r m we define this as the domain
all of the possible inputs for our
transformation and we define this the
codomain
codomain and remember i told you that
the codomain is essentially it's part of
the definition of the function or for of
the transformation and it's the space
that we map to it's not necessarily all
of the things that we're mapping to for
example the image of r and under
transformation it may maybe it's all of
rm or maybe it's some subset of rn the
way you can think about it and i touched
on this in that first video is and
they'll never or at least the linear
algebra books i looked at they didn't
specify this but you can kind of view
this as the range
the range
of t these are the actual
the actual members of rm these are the
actual members of rm that t
maps too that if you take the image of
rn under t you're actually finding so
let me say this is let's say that rm
rm looks like that
rm obviously it'll go in every direction
and let's say that when you take let me
draw rn right here
say this is rn
and we know that t is a mapping from rn
to rn but let's say when you take every
every element of rn and you map them
into rm you let's say you get
some subset of rm let's say you get
something that looks like this so let me
see if i can draw this nicely so you
literally map every point here
and it goes
it
it goes to one of these guys or one of
these guys can be represented as a
mapping from one of these guys one of
these members right here so if you map
all of them you get this subset right
here
this subset is
this is
t
the image of rn
the image of rn under t and in the
terminology that you don't normally see
in linear algebra you can also kind of
consider it its range
the range
of t
now this has a special name this is
called i don't want you get confused
this is called the image of t
image of t
it might be a little confusing image
of t so this is
it's sometimes
written as just i am of t
now you're a little confused here you're
like you know before we're talking about
subsets we would call this the image of
our subset under t and that is the
correct terminology when you're dealing
with the subset but when you take all of
a sudden the entire
n-dimensional space and you're finding
that image we call that the image of the
actual transformation so we can also
call
this set right here
we can call this the image
the image
of
t
and now what is the image of t
well we we know that we can write any
and this is you know literally any so t
is going from r n to r m we can write t
t of x we can write any linear
transformation like this as being equal
to some
matrix some m by n matrix m by n
times
times a vector and these vectors
obviously are going to be members of rn
times some rn
and what is this
so what is the
the the image
let me write it in a bunch of different
ways what is the image
of
of r n
under
t so we could write that as t
let me write this way
we could write that as
t of
rn which is the same thing as the image
of t
notice we're not saying under anything
else because now we're seeing the image
of the actual transformation which we
could also write as
the image
image of t
well what are these equal to these are
equal to the sets
this is equal to the set
of all the transformations of x well all
the transformations of x are going to be
ax
where
x
is a member
x is a member of our n so x is going to
be an n tuple with just
where each element is just has to be a
real number so what is this so if we
write a
let me write my
matrix a
as just a bunch of column vectors
a a1
a2 is going to have n of these right
because it has n
columns
and so a times any x is going to be so
if i multiply that times any x that's a
member of r n i multiply x 1 x1 x2 all
the way to xn
we've seen this multiple multiple times
this is equal to
x1 the scalar x1 times a 1 plus this is
x1 plus x2 times a2
all the way to plus x n
times a n and we're saying we want the
set of all of these sums of these column
vectors where x can take on any vector
in rn which means that the elements of x
can take on any real scalar values so
the set of all of these is essentially
all of the linear combinations of the
columns of a right because i can set
these guys to be equal to any value so
what does that equal to that is equal to
and that we touched on this or we
actually talked about this in our when
we introduced the idea this is equal to
the column span
the column sorry the column space
column column space
of a
or we just denoted it sometimes as c
of
a so that's a pretty neat result if you
take well it's you know it's almost
obvious i mean it's just i'm playing
with words a little bit but any linear
transformation can be represented as a
matrix vector product and so the image
of any linear transformation which means
the subset of its codomain when you map
all of the elements of its domain into
its codomain this is the image of your
transformation this is equivalent to the
column space
the column space
of
the column of of the the matrix that
your transfer that your transformation
could be represented as and the column
space of course is the span
is the span of all the column vectors
of
of your matrix
right this is just the all of the linear
combinations or the span of all of your
column vectors which we do
right here anyway hope you found that a
little interesting and we'll be able to
use these results in the future